one
two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
huh
ah this sucks
help
help
oh wait wait wait wait i'm picking up an
echo signal hell yeah i'm saved over
here
hello maybe you can help me i'm looking
for the family jewel
oh i know
i'm bayless the ship's navigator i'll
prove it here's coordinates for my ass
now
where's the main board
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
huh
uh
oh
what
huh
didn't break a sweat
[Applause]
ugh
come on man you gotta kill it
huh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
oh man i'm out man
damn it was sassy as hell in there it's
stumped
over here in the ratty ass stuff
you just delightful
hey i don't want to talk about it why
are you looking for the family jewel
wainwright jacob said there would be a
vault key fragment in the ship
oh you're with wayne right okay all
right
yeah yeah i'll show you where the family
jewel is
it's in a gorge nearby i can get you
inside
hey i can get that open navigated
[ __ ]
the jewel has seen better days
yeah i had to make an emergency landing
after a disagreement between me and my
combat pilot genevieve
so you got
mutinied sounds better than a messy
break up so we'll just leave it at that
the emergency hatch over there is held
shut with hydraulic lines cut those and
we're in
now that i got you taking back the
jewels gonna be no problem genevieve's
locked it down tight but i know all the
backgrounds
huh
don't look like it now but this thing
used to be one fine ass vessel
felix you little cutie idiot why are you
here didn't i install you in a kid's toy
and toss you out with the
cram
trash
genevieve i got a friend now we're here
for the key fragment i know you got it
in the security hole
oh sorry that's spoken for aurelius said
if i brought it back to her she'd buy me
a dreadnought so i'm gonna do that
not if we get it first we're coming for
that fragment
come on in what you gonna do navigate me
to death try to course up your own ass
i can do more than navigate vault hunter
go through the medical bay
oh crap i navigated
child's club
shut up [ __ ]
huh
uh
time for a fight
huh
gotta hand it to me
i'm a freaking legend
who's next
yes
[Music]
so
foreign
you